>> Bret: I AM BRET BAIER.
VIRGINIA STATE IS CALLING
FOR VIRGINIA'S DEMOCRAT
GOVERNOR TO STEP DOWN NOT
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE SAID
EARLIER IN THE WEEK ABOUT
WHAT CRITICS CALLED
INFANTICIDE.
HIS DESCRIPTION OF A BILL
ABOUT LATE TERM ABORTIONS
BUT, INSTEAD ABOUT A NEW
CONTROVERSY BUBBLING UP LATE
THIS AFTERNOON PHOTO
SURFACED FROM GOVERNOR RALPH
NORTHAM'S YEARBOOKS FROM
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
NEWSPAPER DISCOVERED RACIST
PHOTO ON NORTHAM'S PAGE.
THE PICTURE IS FROM THE 184
EASTERN MEDICAL SCHOOL BOOK.
TWO MEN ONE IN BLACK FACE
AND ONE IN A KU KLUX KLAN
ROBE AND HOOD.
UNCLEAR WHO THE PEOPLE IN
THE COSTUME ARE.
IT IS ON HIS PAGE IN
ADDITION THE DEMOCRATIC'S
GOVERNOR 1981 YEARBOOK LISTS
ONE OF HIS NICKNAMES AS COON
MAN A DEROGATORY TERM.
REACTIONS IS YOU CAN IMAGINE
ONLINE WAS SWIFT AND
CONTROVERSY IS ACTUALLY
GETTING A LOT MORE ATTENTION
THAN HIS DEFENSE OF THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE LATE TERM
ABORTION BILL DID EARLIER
THIS WEEK.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS
NOT RESPONDED TO THE NEW
REPORTS.
NORTHAM DEFENDED HIS LATE
TERM ABORTION DESCRIPTIONS
TODAY HOURS BEFORE THE
YEARBOOK PHOTOS SURFACED.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY IS
FOLLOWING THIS BREAKING
STORY REALLY MINUTES BEFORE
WE GOT ON SET HERE.
HE JOINS ME WITH REACTION IN
THIS PICTURE IS GETTING.
GOOD EVENING.
PETER.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THIS PAGE IN NORTHAM'S 1984
MEDICAL SCHOOL YEARBOOK
FILLED WITH FUTURES OF THE
FUTURE GOVERNOR AND TWO
UNIDENTIFIED PEOPLE ONE IN
BLACK FACE AND ONE IN A KKK
HOOD AND ROBE.
NOW THE VIRGINIA REPUBLICAN
PARTY CHAIRMAN SAYS THIS
RACISM HAS NO PLACE IN
VIRGINIA.
THESE PICTURES ARE WHOLLY
INAPPROPRIATE.
IT GOVERNOR NORTHAM APPEARED
IN BLACK FACE OR DRESSED IN
A KKK ROBE HE SHOULD RESIGN
IMMEDIATELY AND THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNCIL KELLYANNE
CONWAY SEES SHADES AT
KAVANAUGH HEARING YEARBOOKS YEAB
KAVANAUGH HEARING YEARBOOKS YEAO
KAVANAUGH HEARING YEARBOOKS YEAS
WERE USED TO TRY TO BOOK UP
UNPROVEN ACCUSATIONS SHE
QUEATED THIS IS SHOULD BE
EASIER WARNING THAN PARSING
EVERY WORD AND SEMICOLON IN
THE KAVANAUGH YEARBOOK.
TURNING UP THE HEAT ON THE
GOVERNOR ALREADY FEELING
PLENTY AFTER SUPPORT FAILING
MEASURE THAT WOULD HAVE
PERMITTED WHAT A LOT OF
CRITICS DEFINE AS
INFANTICIDE.
>> IF A MOTHER IS IN LABOR I
CAN TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
THE INFANT WOULD BE
DELIVERED.
THE INFANT WOULD BE KEPT
COMFORTABLE.
THE INFANT WOULD BE
RESUSCITATED IF THAT'S WHAT
THE MOTHER AND FAMILY
DESIRED AND THEN A
DISCUSSION WOULD ENSUE.
>> NORTHAM RAN A PRIMARY
AGAINST TOM AND COMPETITIVE
GENERAL ELECTION AGAINST
REPUBLICAN ED GILLESPIE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THIS
YEARBOOK PAGE HAS SURFACED
IN PUBLIC.
>> Bret: YOU SEE ONLINE ON
OF THESE PEOPLE WHO COVER
POLITICS BOY IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT EITHER IN THE
PRIMARY OR THE GENERAL
ELECTION THESE THINGS
WEREN'T PICKED UP.
EACH ONE OF THESE TEAMS HAS
OPPO RESEARCH ARM.